have you ever seen a Sci-Fi dystopian
movie or book where people are forced to
home migrants in their own homes
because I'm thinking about it and I'm
like well there's the the one where they
give everyone drugs there's the one
where everyone's locked in their house
there's the one where they're burning
all the books um there's the one where
the pigs are in charge is there one
where it's like you live in a house and
then one day they show up with a guy
from a foreign country like he lives
here now
well here's the story from mediaite New
York city mayor Eric Adams suggests
locals could eventually house migrants
in their own homes for extra cash that's
right discussion took place on Monday
during an address at City Hall
Adams announced their how that houses of
worship had stepped up around the city
volunteering to open up their doors to
assist with giving migrants places to
stay a clip from the announcement began
circulating on Twitter via Greg price
according to ABC7 the new two-year
partnership with the New York Disaster
Interfaith services will allow up to 50
houses of worship or faith-based spaces
to offer overnight shelter for up to 19
single adult men at each location
great this step was for the first of
many yada yada he says they have spare
rooms they have locales and if you can
find a way to get over the 30-day Rule
and other rules the government has in
place we can take that 4.2 billion 4.3
now
that we potentially have to spend and we
can put it back in the pockets of
everyday New Yorkers every day houses of
worship instead of putting in the
pockets of Corporations they're
basically saying
you are going to have illegal immigrants
living in your home
but don't worry we'll pay you
I didn't see that one coming it's kind
of the third amendment by violation in
it I mean that's stating it he hasn't
enlisted to the minority but yeah well
it's not they're not soldiers but the
same maybe it's a private property
rights Fourth Amendment maybe I don't
know but it's clearly a property rights
violation there's a viral video coming
out of Chicago where people are at a
city meeting and they're saying that
they're going to be bringing in like 250
adult men illegal immigrants and these
people are screaming like are you insane
how could you do this and it's funny
because the people on the panel or
whatever are smugly saying we are going
to do this this and this and it's just
like y'all voted for it you keep voting
for the same thing you mark the D every
time
and then what happens is they smack you
around they strip you of your rights and
you go how could this have happened to
me again for a hundred years Chicago you
have been voting in Democrats and it
keeps getting worse dude I can't tell
you how it gets worse non-stop in
Chicago I know but you have to give them
the 50th chance oh yeah they're like the
police in Chicago are operating black
sites where they kidnap people and lock
them up for 10 days and no one knows
where they go it's like okay why did
your grandfather your father and you
vote for it
I just I can't live I can't I'm sorry
dude I'm out of Chicago I left yeah
because it's like after the crime just
got worse after the policies got worse
and everyone's like I'm gonna vote
Democrat again this time I'm like I
completely relate to your exasperation
because I was born and raised in
California and I watched the same thing
and we just kept voting for more and
more taxes and and you know increasing
the size of the state and it just slowly
destroyed the state and I think that's
the same thing that's happening maybe
not with the outskirts of Illinois but
certainly Chicago itself it's like a
third world hellhole I remember in the
Summer of Love riots there was a viral
leaked audio clip
Chicago's got aldermen they're like
neighborhood politicians they're in
charge of these various neighborhoods
and apparently it's been a long time
since I covered it but they when the
riots were happening downtown they
basically lifted the bridges to force
the Riders into neighborhoods to protect
the financial areas sacrificing the
residential areas well that's what you
get yeah you keep voting for it over and
over and over again they keep doing it
they did again they voted for that far
left guy yeah there you go they replaced
uh Beetlejuice with an even scarier
figure that's even possible I think one
of the most frustrating Parts about New
York City though is that they have begun
busing to the counties outside right so
like Eric Adam believes that the
decision he makes for this major pop
popular city is the decision he's making
for the state right and that's psychotic
basically in my opinion and there are
different County elected officials who
have filed lawsuits they're fighting
this but he has decided since he is
accepting migrants he also gets to
install basically fraternity houses of
unmarried single immigrants in your
neighborhoods wherever he sees fit
that's crazy to me
not the mayor of these counties he's
only the mayor of New York City well I
think this is ultimately why even though
people laugh it off uh peaceful National
divorce is happening in real time I mean
the the migration of people like myself
or Tim that are fleeing these blue hell
holes is like that's that is what
national divorce will look like
ultimately is that people that share my
ideology that don't want an over uh you
know overpowerful State we're going to
go and be amongst our people we all saw
last week that YouTube announced you can
now deny the 2020 election again I know
which is just as a weird policy timing
but it's because they're intending to
deny yeah Trump's win Trump trump wins
in 2024 they are going to scream about
you name the country oh China
now because you know I don't know
whatever who knows what Russia will be
they're gonna they're gonna claim Russia
got Trump elected again because you
trained did it that'd be interesting
well they wouldn't say that because
they're they're fighting with Ukraine
they're gonna say Russia did it to stop
to so that Trump would stop helping
Ukraine then they're going to come up
look there's going to be AI fake
evidence there's gonna be AI fake images
I'm pretty sure newsouts are already
using AI images
pretty sure we use AI images at
timcast.com but they're edited to look
like art it's not like a picture we'll
cut the person out and put them over
something and it looks cartoony and it's
not we don't use it as supporting
evidence in article we use it completely
as just yeah but this is what I I so I
can't say for sure but I've seen
articles that look like it's Ai and it's
it's not the it's not the article of the
subject I'm sorry it's not the image of
the subject it isn't a related image so
a typical thing is they'll say like
you'll get an article and it'll be like
you know new drug approved by FDA and
it'll just show like a hand with a
purple glove like injecting something
it's totally unrelated to stock
photograph it looks like they're using
AI stock photographs but people could
confuse as being the real thing but
anyway I digress when it comes to the
election yeah they're gonna pull out all
the stops
I think right now strong possibility
Trump wins we'll see don't know for sure
strong possibility and we already saw
with the Boston Globe report in the
Democrats war game
they said if Trump wins they will
encourage the west coast to secede from
the union which
can you hear what where they floated a
poll of people saying like would you be
open to succession and it was the South
and the West Coast that were like sounds
good they were the most in support of
they were support across the country but
it was the South and West Coast that
were like we are willing to split up
yeah it's like acceptable I don't hate
you I just don't want you to rule over
me anymore it's pretty straightforward I
just I just want to not have to have
to live amongst people that hate me and
that's how it feels now and it's it's
weird because it happened so like what
seemingly overnight but I think even the
people on the left feel it too like you
guys if you're if your perception of our
of our protests about Target or Bud
Light or anything like that is that we
hate rainbows well you're not even
attempting to understand our worldview
like you you see us as caricatures like
I understand your pres your position
better than you've even begun to
understand there's been more than a few
studies that have shown that right that
people who are right-leaning individuals
are very much more likely to be able to
grasp the concepts of someone who is
left-leaning or a leftist yeah uh than
vice versa because when you are a
right-leaning person you are constantly
inundated with views that are not your
own whether because if you're in an
airport you're seeing CNN if you're on
and you're driving in your car it's NPR
if you are a left-wing individual you're
almost forced into an echo chamber that
you didn't even ask for because you're
never ever even given the chance to look
for view you have to actively go look
for those views let me let me prove the
case this is very easy to prove this
the war in Ukraine how in the hell did
they convince the left that spending
over a hundred billion dollars on a war
that they don't know anything about
these people have debated them they
don't know anything about the history in
Ukraine they don't they know nothing
about not put Ukraine on a map no but
they know nothing nothing at all we've
had lefties on the show and they just go
oh I don't know about that yeah exactly
or or you know oh I didn't read that in
the New York Times so it can't be true I
mean that was what Destiny's you know
rejoinder was to in my debate with him
but that's that's how you know in my
opinion that the right now consists of
the critical thinking folks it hasn't
always been that way certainly during
the wmds in Iraq it wasn't that way but
it is now they're the critical thinkers
the people on the left are like drones
they're not thinking at all it's crazy
to witness that started all the way up
through Obama though right like they
whether they knew it or not they were
slowly pushed pro-war true because it
just never stopped right well they said
it was going to end it just kept going
they hid that though they hid his drone
campaigns they didn't talk about the
thousands of Innocents that were
murdered from from the sky robots by
Obama but then the war in Ukraine you
can't hide that the people don't ever
know about that we still invaded more
countries under Obama it's just that it
wasn't reported on as widely Syria Libya
yeah yeah so that was more Hillary
Clinton in my in my blame Spectrum but
yes but but it's it's still under that
neoliberal establishment so a lot of
those people are still whether they
admit it or not uh they were pushed to
that perspective and they just don't
realize that it's like it's really funny
because I watch a lot of old Hollywood
and they are just pro-war like it's
really like the movies maybe from a
bigger director might do something
that's that pushes like an anti-war
stance back in the day but in the end
they still make these movies that still
push pro-us government pro-us government
policies it's just it's Bonkers now to
see people who are pushing it and they
don't really understand because they
heard Russia bad Russia invaded
therefore Russia bad yeah and that's
really as far as they need to take it
because it's a one-dimensional level of
thinking that goes beyond that doesn't I
don't think people want to hold on to
thought that takes more than 10 seconds
to explain we have no attention span
anymore if I were to mention Crimea I
think everyone would be like that's
irrelevant I have no idea how that's
connected at all
region the eight-year Civil War the
bombing campaigns like they're like it's
too much Russia's bad I'm gonna and I'm
completely completely fine with that if
they
if they put a flag in your in your bio
and then exactly like it's one thing to
to just say look I don't know and I
don't care right I like I can almost
respect that more like you just choose
to not engage you can choose not to
engage but you don't get to then put a
symbol for the opposing argument in your
profile I disagree I think people who
identify as left-leaning in any capacity
feel obligated to show outward signs
that they are with the cult remember the
mask thing do you remember the blacks
the people saying that oh no I you know
if I I I'm still going to keep wearing a
mask even though they don't have to
because people think I'm Republican if I
take it off right yeah yeah it's it's
all about signaling and and being in uh
in group signaling I did hear people on
the right say look I don't want to wear
a mask in there because they'll think
I'm a leftist as well it doesn't make
sense it's just it's like but no one no
one would choose to wear a mask for for
no reason no one would just be like for
literally no reason I'll put no reason
I'll put a mask on so conservatives were
the people who are alike I would prefer
to wear a mask if they were the opposite
and then Liberals are the people who are
like I don't don't care if I need to or
not people will think I'm conservative
if I don't I still see I saw somebody in
a car the other day with a mask on by
themselves like yeah I thought that was
long gone wild I felt your outrage I
felt that day one because I was like
you're by yourself there's nothing you
can be protecting yourself from nothing
at all remember those like clean car
stickers you know like the back of the
car would have like those clean like the
clean air stickers right here's
something in California probably yeah I
like the people playing the flute with
the with the cut hole in the mask and I
heard people like actually rationalizing
it who are saying like look look like
they're talking like you're stupid
they're look they need you to get re
used to seeing people wearing a mask it
totally makes sense I'm like no because
like in Minnesota the like the state
government was having people do Zoo
meetings with masks on and there were
people who were like look it's fine it's
like they want to get you used to seeing
what people look like with a mascot I'm
like so they think you're an idiot like
what I mean I knew people who
quarantined spouses in their own
bedrooms and you're like you all breath
same hair in your house like maybe that
minimizes some risk but I really feel
like it's not it's not what you think I
don't think it's as effective as you
think it is uh I think the strangest
part of covet is that as much as we are
like obviously the math thing is crazy
you should like it's over uh there are
still sort of uh ruins of this time
period like I was thinking about I was
at an Outback Steakhouse the other
weekend and there were you know how they
have the booths and for a while they
were like okay you can go to restaurants
if the if the restaurants constructs
extra tall sort of blockers to keep
germs from jumping the table I guess or
I don't know what but they're still
there and people are used and you don't
even think about them anymore and you
don't see them go to Atlantic City all
the casinos not all of them but a lot of
them have actually I think all of them
might gigantic plastic barriers bolted
to all their table games so when you sit
down you have this Plexiglas room that
you're in and your hands can go
underneath it I remember when I was in
Vegas in like 21 and I saw those for the
first time and I was like oh I live live
in a dystopic novel like this is this
sucks are they still there in Vegas I
don't think so I think they they took
them down but but these things are there
in a lot of places but but see uh you're
you're talking about the physical relics
I I want people to not forget about the
the spiritual relics that exists within
the youth and as well as all of us
ultimately we all carry some sort of
trauma yeah
the kids who are not going to be able to
read facial expressions as accurately as
others because in their formative years
they were raised with the entire
generation of parents who were too
scared to spend time around their kids
without a mask on they weren't scared
they were doing it because they were
they have they have some kind of weird
cult attachment where they want their
neighbors to see them in masks no I
believe that a lot of the ones that if
they're doing it around their kid
they're legitimately scared and they've
just been propagandized so heavily by
the media that they're terrified of
their own shadow sure some of them but
there's that famous story of the
munchausen's by proxy mom who cut out
her daughter's uh salivary glands and
their teeth fell out of her head and
then she got a boyfriend and then she
killed her mom yeah I think there are a
lot of parents who are like the
neighbors might see you put your mask on
like they didn't actually care there's
like I want people to see but I think
that you know Josie talks about this all
the time it's like we are just suffering
under three straight years of much
answered by proxy on a grand scale and
uh it just it feels like the the people
that are speaking up on the behalf of
the kids are somehow being painted as as
the Dangerous Ones and that's so bizarre
and inverted and feels kind of satanic
if I'm being honest and this is coming
from someone who's agnostic but it
really does feel like there's a
possession that's taken over yeah weird
but I think aliens are demons which one
do you think it is I prefer to be aliens
because I don't want to go down the
biblical line of thinking because I have
some great news for you just breaking
today aliens are coming yeah but here's
the thing if it's demons at least
there's Angels if it's aliens it's just
aliens true then you're on your own but
maybe they're benevolent the aliens that
are brainwashing people and turning them
into cultists no no no I'm talking like
they're here to save us from the
brainwashing cultists that we live
amongst easier it's just the media it's
just the media being evil in all reality
it's a cult and these things happen and
we can look through history and see they
come and go in waves you can look at all
the different revolutions throughout
history for whatever extremist ideology
and they follow similar patterns yeah
but they didn't have the you know I
always wonder how the internet's going
to affect that now because information
is spread so much farther and so much
faster and you reach people so much
easier now that we've never experienced
this type of Revolution through this
type of means where information is so
easily accessed it's like we talk about
like you can't just deprogram someone
now if all of their ideology and all
their cult leanings come from the
internet because as soon as you get them
out what do you do just ban them from
the internet for Life thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for on
censored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time